by the way congratulations I mean even
from the very first it's been 17 years
first of all what is that old you can
have it thank you I haven't drink out of
it it's essential water if you like it I
might want to get a rabies 17 years I
would have never thought that show would
have had the impact that Emmie look at
what it did the domino effect like was
crazy I actually genuinely do not
believe we would be sitting here today
if you hadn't entered the show
I mean the whole premise of this show
was we had to find a star who was gonna
sell records you know we found some
great people that that whole year but
when you delivered that moment on that
first live show
and when you sang that winning song at
the end it was a game at the end that
the finale and said wow this thing is
really gonna work I think that was the
moment that we knew do you it wasn't it
crazy cuz I remember Nicki and just now
II had no idea like we've ended up in
the top threw me had no idea the show
had blown up like it had cuz we were on
that bubble I could have been I think
that's when it hit all of us we were
like wait what maybe in the balcony say
yes that we turned out that night at the
final and we were looking forward to it
thinking you know we've worked hard to
get to this point we turn up at the
Dolby theater where I saw you a couple
of weeks ago yeah and we were taken to
the very very very top we shot your show
from here and they went you're not
judging it I mean what we're supposed to
be doing just watch
they told us tonight we were doing that
duet that we did live on national
television like three minutes before
live national television started
literally we both are standing they were
like what you guys remember what we saw
her it was like a VFW like a veteran's
home like really we literally started
from the bottom and now we're here I
freaked out cuz I was like
[Applause]
I had literally a just moved back from
LA my place had burned down I was living
in my car for three days here and then
finally was like I got to go home and so
many told me about the audition and I
literally walked and I had no idea what
I was doing I didn't know it's a TV show
until the audition I was in front of
y'all I was like Paula Abdul's here Sam
Solomon yes also did recognize Randy
because I knew he had played with Mariah
and I was like and because you'll ask me
to sing another song cuz I sang at last
then you said see another song and I
literally sat there going singing any
song but it should get you out cuz
everyone was seeing that it did get you
everyone was doing Lady Marmalade I was
like any song but that and then out of
nowhere express yourself came out it I
don't know why that was like one of the
most exciting days but I I have another
well an and on that day when she
auditioned I knew you were gonna win oh
really well I you think I did I never
watched these shows but I saw some woman
named Callie older woman on America's
Got Talent that was unbelievable the
other day she's like 60 years old some
she's ridiculously good time and you
stood up who you stood up and gave her a
standing ovation that was the VMAs I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this